i think you have to play h4
otherwise you're just losing
and yeah actually i want to show last
time the last touch
of the world champion okay okay okay
it's just i mean like if you move the
bishop i'll just go okay what
you cannot move the king yeah he's
fascinating
bishop bishop e1 no king he's three isis
no then rookie yeah also yes yeah not
bishop
one or if you and if you go okay far
then this king is free
it's game over beautiful full domination
what is he doing cookie two
ah stalemate
[Music]
okay that's just simply israel
what first played king c5 will be played
it's a piss up
okay
yeah okay you're saying it's like
handshake resigned from irontie
good game from uh magnus except at some
point
we felt he could that it would have been
should have been a bit faster the
conversion from a guide position
uh controlling after d5 it was relegated
controlling the wall board center
but anyway it was never really in doubt
oh good yeah i i
it looks like well yeah that
it was the whole game that that
i am thai was so passive